for all the new faces on the screen many
of solos cold mainstays in the Star Wars
universe with their destinies already
laid out we know Lando betrays Han on
Cloud City
we know Han eventually meets Leia has a
kid and gets light stabbed and we know
Chewbacca hates ports but what about the
other characters in solo a Star Wars
story true to form the movie is a
menagerie of aliens droids and rebel
scum and believe it or not a few of
those characters come into play in other
Star Wars stories here are all the
characters in solo a Star Wars story
with more meaning than you realized
spoilers ahead obviously l33 seven ever
since the beginning the Millennium
Falcon has seems to have a mind of its
own
way back in the Empire Strikes Back
c-3po mentions that the Falcon has the
most peculiar dialect after trying to
communicate with it and now we know why
thanks to a new character who's
apparently been in all the main Star
Wars films l-3 37 Lando's activist droid
by herself she's a unique piece of work
as solo co-writer Jon Kasdan explained
she's a self modified droid the idea is
that she's sort of a mutt if you will of
various parts of different kinds of
droids who has improved upon herself but
when Han Lando Chewie and Kira are
trying to navigate the Maelstrom they
have no choice but to plug the defunct
elf threes database into the Falcons
computer and as far as we can tell they
leave it there giving the ship l33 seven
thoughts and sassiness weasel by now
most people know that solo a Star Wars
story features a surprise cameo by a
character from the Phantom Menace and
we'll get to that in a moment
but what you may not have realized is
there were actually two phantom
characters on screen and solo the
character of weasel played by star wars
mainstay Warwick Davis is one of
emphasis Marauders and Solo as it turns
out he's taken a long journey to end up
as one of nests rebels in the Phantom
Menace weasel again played by Davis
appears as one of the spectators of
Anakin's podrace
he even bets on anakin to come in first
the official guide to solo a Star Wars
story seems to confirm him as the same
character saying that he was once a
petty thief who worked for Jabba the
Hutt what's he been up to in the
meantime probably regretting that bet he
made on Anakin since he turned out to be
a Sith Lord at all cloud riders one of
the best additions to Solo was an fost
and her band of cloud riders a pirate
gang that seemed
show up at every job han polled as it
turns out these guys hark back to the
marvel line of comics as well in Star
Wars number nine Han is called out to a
planet to stop the cloud riders raids on
a local village
there he goes blaster two blaster with
the airborne Marauders the story is
obviously different from what happened
in solo but co-writer Jon Kasdan
confirmed that the name for the club
writers came directly from that comic
issue along with the design ideas for
the gang swoop bikes with this as a
precedent who knows what other non-canon
expanded universe concepts could still
make it to the big screen Darth Maul
Solo had a big surprise waiting near the
end in the form of Darth Maul who you
may remember as the red-faced syp who
got a free case of the halfsies courtesy
of obi-wan in the Phantom Menace this
was a particularly bad case of somebody
being cut in half so first of all what
how's that guy still around
well Darth Maul is if nothing else a
slippery sucker and fans of the animated
series the Clone Wars may recall that
Maul survived being cut in half and
falling into that giant hole later he
got himself a fancy new pair of Robo
legs and became the leader of the
criminal organization called the shadow
collective so how does this all fit into
solo well clearly Maul is connected to
the crimson dawn the criminal
organization headed by dryden boss in
the film whether Maul pulls all the
strings for the dawn or vos simply
reports to him is still unclear but
dryden boss mentions that he can't steal
the co axiom from Kessel because he has
an alliance with a pike syndicate who
run the mine in Star Wars Canon the pike
syndicate our members of maules shadow
collective suggesting that the crimson
dawn is just another criminal
organization working for malls bigger
gangster group Kira
similarly the movies ending makes it
clear that we haven't seen the last of
Kira as one of Hans many betrayers
she certainly has her place in solo but
as an ally of maul while things just got
a lot more interesting one theory has
her becoming a Sith but probably that's
not likely since maul himself
technically isn't a Sith anymore but he
still has all the training and if he
took Kira under his wing there are
definitely a few things he could teach
her
combined with Kira's knowledge of the
tourists Cassie fighting style the same
style the last Jedi's praetorian guard
used that could make her a formidable
opponent in the future thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus to
all this cool stuff we know you'll love
to
[Music]